I think we are losing people
but so um I just want to say something
about the discussions um in in the end
of the day so we have been
very um flexible about the discussion
like just um expected people to self
organize and
according to their interests but um Reen
point out that maybe it's more effective
if we actually have at least some
motivating question of the day right
that people can think about it and then
maybe we can actually connect people
right through these motivating questions
and I think reena's suggestions was um
to um maybe a good starting poting
starting pointing is to say well we are
all talking about
circuits but where do these uh circuits
come from right I think from for
different groups the circuits come from
different places so they can be compiled
from some model and then what is this
model usually the model is in some
representation they can be learned
directly from data they can be obtained
from um a search process from some model
as well right so um maybe we could try
to talk about that like when we um how
how do we obtain circuits do we even
actually obtain the circuits or we just
use it as a like a conceptual phrase
work but we never really build the
circuit do we even want to build the
circuit um stuff like that Reena do you
want to say some words
about I think you said uh you said it
right uh this was one question I had I
don't want but that I don't want to take
the time the other question I have uh is
a what's beyond circuits because
circuits obviously represent tractable
reasoning you assume you have a circuit
in memory it's a uh small I mean you can
have it only if things are not blowing
up and normally in AI we start from
let's say a graphical model or we start
from a search base and we assume that
the underlying graph is exponential so
you can try to compile but often the
circuits or the search space that is
let's say end or it's exponential you
cannot fit it in memory uh so what's
going on and how I we should go at some
point and address problems that cannot
be solved by circuits uh one H so I I'm
curious what people think about it my
own thinking was to use it as a uh
approximation scheme like lower bound
and stuff like that uh and another
suggestion that I have that maybe will
take us forward in the in the direction
of addressing this is the benchmarks so
each Community has its own problems that
they're focusing on in UI uncertainty in
AI we do have this competition and those
who are engaging in model counting for
instance addressing the same problem
that we address in uh solving
probalistic inference partition function
probability of evidence and there are
Benchmark there are competitions that we
uh conduct primarily in order to bring
people from different commun ities to
address the same problem so I
encourage this community the a model
counting Community whether with circuits
or other means to open and come and
suggest problem suggest representation
and try to uh compare their their
algorithms with other approaches U that
people engaging in in UI and this may
also push in the direction of looking at
common problems okay
okay thank you so by the end of the day
we will come back to this questions
right so like the other days we come
back from the last cough break of the
day to the to the room I mean who wants
to take part in the discussion okay so
am please hello everyone my name
is and in this talk I will give
an overview on the foundations of
factorized databases and draw some
connections to knowledge compilation and
probalistic
databases the foundations of uh
factorized databases were introduced in
an um icdt
200 12 paper by Dano and Jacob zne and a
few years later the aers also published
an extended version of their work at
tots 20
2015 um I got in touch with factorized
databases when I joined uh
the research group of Dan alanu at the
beginning of 201 and 17 and my
subsequent work
had a lot to do with factorized uh
databases my main research focus is
incremental view maintenance and also
there we are using many tools and ideas
from
factorized databases to for instance
get first case optimal update times for
conjunctive
queries factorized uh databases are
based on two fundamental observation
first the listing represent presentation
of query results can
entail repetitions which
are redundant and
this redundancy can be avoided using
uh suin yet lossless
factorized representation and we are
using the
term factorization to remind you
of
basic arithmetic
uh operation where we exploit the
distributivity law between sum and
product we have some effective tools for
factorize representations which allow us
to do efficient computation in the
factorized domain first of all we have
representation systems which uh yeah
representation systems like variable
orders
which describe
the uh structure of uh factorizations
then we can compute factorized
representations in first case optimal
time which means the time to compute the
factorized uh representation is
proportional in the size of the
representation and from a factorized um
presentation we
can enumerate the tupl in
the query answer one by one with
constant delay and this is as good
as enumerating from the listing
representation let me give you a small
example to give you an idea how um
factorized databases are defined let's
say we are given this simple
database that consists of three
relations orders pizza and ingredients
in the order relation we have customers
and for each customer we have the day of
the order and the pizza that has been
ordered then we have the pizza relation
for each Pizza it gives uh its
ingredients and we have the ingredients
relation which gives for each ingredient
its price now when we look at
the listing representation of the
natural joint of these three relation
then we see that there are some
repetitions for instance Dan uh repeats
a lot and also the pizza pilia repeats
and then in the context of Dan and pilia
we have the repetition of the day
Thursday and
Friday now uh to go one step
towards factorization let's Express this
listing uh representation as
an uh
algebraic as
a relational algebra expression using
product and Union so each Tuple is now
represented as a set of values which are
concatenated by product and we get all
the tuples by taking the union of all
these uh
terms now if you want to factorize
this uh representation we first need to
come up with a variable order a variable
order shows the or reveals the
conditional Independence between the
variables and this information we
can directly get from the query uh
structure so this variable order I have
here says given a pizza the day and
customer on one side is
conditionally independent from the
ingredient and its price now from this
we can construct
a factorized representation of our query
uh result we start at the top with a
union which uh unions all the pizzas we
have and then under each Pizza we have a
cartisian product of the day and
customer on one side and
the ingredient and price on the other
side so if you look for instance under
basilia we
have uh a product here so this value is
concatenated with the tupal we get from
this part and here we have a union of
the days and then each day is again uh
concatenated with the
corresponding customer depending on
which variable order we use we can can
get
different equivalent factorized
representations which can differ in size
right it depends on how much do we
exploit the uh conditional Independence
between the variables now if we want to
get even
more uh compression we can look into the
dependencies of the variables so what we
do is we look at each
variable and check on which other
variables on the root path the variable
depends on and we say that two variables
depend on each other if they appear in
the same relation Pizza is at the top it
doesn't have any variable on top so
it's dependency set is empty they
depends on pizza ingredient depends on
Pizza customer depends on both pizza and
day but the
interesting part is here that price only
depends on ingredient but not on Pizza
which means for any uh combination of
pizza and in in ingredient we don't need
to repeat uh the price for
each in in ingredient we can store we
can cach the price and when we can cach
it once
and whenever we need it we can point to
the cached
data and in the factorized
representation it would look like this
as you can see here we have here tomato
and mozzarella in this part of the tree
and also in this part of the tree but we
represent the prices only once and from
this part of the tree we would just
point to the first
part uh now let's uh have a look at
factorized representations from the
perspective of
knowledge compilation from the
perspective of knowledge compilation
factorized
representations correspond to correspond
to Circus which are deterministic
decomposable smooth multivalued and
order that they are deterministic
because all child trees of a union node
are distinct they are decomposable
because all child trees of a product Noe
are over disjoint variable sets they are
smooth because all child trees of a
union node are over the same variable
set they
are multivalued because of variable can
have
several values in its domain and they
are ordered because all child trees of a
union node are over the
same variable order now let's see how uh
Factor representations can be useful so
what kind of operation can we do on on
them and here is a list of some of the
operations we can
do directly in the compressed domain so
we don't need to expand the
factorization to do these operations for
instance we can do joints however the
size of the output now can grow it
depends on uh the factorization with of
the result and I I will talk later a bit
more uh about what this means we can do
selection we can do this operation in
linear time if the selection variables
are on top of the other variables if
this is not the case we might need to re
structure our factorization this could
lead to a blow up in complexity we can
do projections again we can do this
in linear time in the size of the uh
factorization if the
projection variables are on
top we get constant delay enumeration of
the output toes as I said before and we
can even uh enumerate in in a specific
order in case the enumeration order is
compatible with my variable order we can
do Aggregates like uh count some product
and group by I will give some
examples on this and in case of group by
if the group by variables are again at
the top of my variable order I can do
this operation in linear time and we can
do efficient Updates this is a topic
where I'm specifically interested in the
update time depends on a with measure
which we call Dynamic width and we
studied this P measure in several papers
for different class classes of
conjunctive
queries now let's see how much
compression gain we get by factorization
in practice and in terms of asymptotic
complexity here you see the result of an
experiment done on uh a
synthetic data set so we took our pizza
or the data set
and scaled it up and we were interested
about the comparison between the
compression we get by factorization
compared to the compression we get uh by
uh compressing the data using
gzip the listing representation we uh
encoded in a CSV file so comma separated
value tech text format and the
factorized representation be encoded in
plain text so if we first look at the uh
this red line the main takeaway message
here is so this red line shows us the
compression ratio of the listing
representation over the factorized
representation what we can see here that
the larger the data gets the more
uh compression ratio we obtain the green
line shows the compression ratio between
the listing representation and the gzip
listing representation overall you see
uh with yeah overall the compression
ratio is less and the compression ratio
does not necessarily increase with
increasing data one reason for this is
that gzip is not able to to uh
recognize distant repetitions in the
data the blue line is the compression
ratio of the factorized representation
versus the gzip factorized
representation here the compression
ratio is even less this is expectable
because in the factor representation
there is not much repetition so there is
not much gzip could do and again with
increasing data we see that the
compression ratio does not increase we
did also some experiments on real world
data set here you see the uh results on
a data sets which is from the retailer
domain where we have one big inventory
table which contains 84 million tups and
this table basically stores for
each uh inventory unit how many of them
were sold in which shop on which day and
then we have many small Dimension tables
which say something about the location
of the shop about the weather on
specific days and so on what is
important here that the joints are key
for key joints so it should not Beed
that factorization brings here much
because we don't have the n * n
cartisian product explosion but still
even in this case so when we join the
big inventory table with a
smaller uh Dimension tables we see a
compression factor of up to uh 26 times
and when we join the big table with the
larger Dimension tables we get even uh
compression factor of up to
times how about the asymptotic
complexities Alano and saot have shown
that given any
conjunctive quy q and database
D um
the result of Q of D has a factorized
representation which uses caching of
size o of D to the power of um s up
aror uh of Q and this s up Arrow of Q we
call
the factorization width of the query and
I will explain later a bit more in
detail uh how this is defined but first
let's look at some implications for full
conjunctive this bond is astical TI
which means that there is exists large
databases such that all factorizations
following variable orders meet
this um their size meet
this upper
bound as you all know the listing
representation of query results can have
size uh the size of the input database
to the power of RAR of Q where RAR of Q
is the fractional
cover number and the gap between the
factorization wi as up Arrow of Q and
RAR of Q can be up to the number of
relation I have minus one and it we can
also show that um for full
conjunctive
queries factorized representations can
be computed in first case optimal time
up to a logarithmic factor in the input
database size so this means our
computation time will
be proportional to the uh size of the
factorization we
compute now let's try to relate this
factorization with with known uh with
measures for instance let's take
the fractional hyper tree with now if we
get a variable order for our query we
can translate it into a free connect
hyper decomposition for
the query by free connects we mean that
uh all three variables of our Cy are
contained in a connected sub tree and
the factor the fractional hyper of our
hyper tree will be the same as the
factor factorization with of the query
there is also a translation in the other
direction so given any free Connex hyper
Tre de composition we
can translate it into a variable order
whose factorization withth is at most as
high as the fractional hyper of the fre
Conex hyper tree decomposition we uh
started with and this implies that the
factorization with is equal to the
fractional hyper of our query now
fractional hyper
trius generalized from Boolean uh
queries
to conjunctive
queries so let me uh list some of
the areas where
factorized representations are used us
for in so in recent years we have uh
seen a lot of work which are connected
to factorized databases which use ideas
and tools from uh factorized databases
one area is the area of graph data
representation and processing the reason
here is when you when we want
to uh walk through a graph we need
basically to join to comput a join Over
The Edge relation and this can result in
high uh this can result
in join results which are large and
which can be factorized very
well factorized representations or tools
of factorized representations are also
used in static and dynamic
query evaluation especially in the field
of
dynamic
query evaluation we can show that if we
want to maintain the result of a
conjunctive query then to obtain worst
case optimal update time instead of
maintaining the full listing
representation one can maintain the
factorized representation and in this
way we can obtain first Cas optimal
update time and it gives
us all we need so we can
then enumerate from the factor as
representation all
the output to with
constant delay factorized
representations are also used in the
area of quy Provence Management in the
computation of Aggregates I will later
show some examples so factorized
representations
come very handy if we want to compute
Aggregates like counts
some some product Aggregates we can
usually do it in one pass over the
factorized representation and factorized
databases are also very useful
in machine learning task the reason here
being that
many the the core computation of
many machine learning tasks can be
broken down to the computation of
Aggregates on the uh input data and
since we can do this very well if the
input data is factorized so this gives
us
um efficient tools for uh for instance
training machine learning models now in
the rest of my talk I would like to uh
show two use cases of factorized
representations in a bit more detail and
the first use case would be
probabilistic databases let's again look
at our
simple database example this time we
only have orders and pizza to keep it
simple and since we are now in the
probabilistic setting we add to
each relation an additional column for
the
independent random variable so each
Tuple now gets a
random variable and for each of these
variables we have a
probability distribution which tells us
the probability that this variable is
true now let's look at this simple query
which joins uh ordas and pizzas and ask
whether there is at least one Tuple in
the join and in the context of
probabilistic databases the answer to
this qu would be the probability that
this
uh that the result is not empty
if we have a closer look at this query
then we see that the query is
hierarchical danu gave already the
definition of uh hierarchical queries
just to recap so for any two variables
we look at the sets of the atoms in
which they appear and these sets must
either be disjointed or one set should
be included in the other set and this
holds for this
query so in this case uh we know from
the work of tal and suu that in this
case we can do probability computation
in linear time in the size of the input
database and in the following I would
like to show how we can uh recover
this result
using factorized
representations let's first look at the
dnf of the the fully
expanded dnf of the query
Provence
um so for each pair of tuples which join
we have here
a conjunction of their
variables now if we have a closer look
at this uh dnf formula we see that it
contains some structure for instance the
variable o1 appears several times O2
appears several times it's same for O3
and o4 and also the first row on the in
the highlighted block appears twice and
also here we see
some repetition and this calls for
factorization what we can do we can pull
out the all variables from each of these
conjuncts and then we get this
factorized expression which still
includes some repetitions so we can go
even further and obtain
this uh
factorized expression which we call now
F ones because every variable appears at
most once and once um
yeah now uh I will show you how we can
get to this compressed form
without going through
the dnf so to compute it directly from
the input data so what we do here we we
again start with our uh variable order
but now we extend our variable order
with notes at the leaps which stand for
the
variables since
our query is hierarchical each root to
Le pass so we can construct a variable
order where each root to Leaf pass
corresponds to a relation and then at
the leaf of that pass we can add the
node for the random variable and then we
can build our factorization as I
explained uh before and now at the leavs
we will have our
random variables now if you
focus on
The Logical operators and the leaves and
we restrict the tree to those nodes when
then we get exactly the
factorization which uh we have in the
expression I show at the top and once we
have this now we can do efficient
probability computation first we turn
the or notes into a sum note and the end
notes into
a product note we now give this um
operations a new meaning which is
tailored
to probability computation and I
will illustrate how they are defined so
to get the uh probability of the whole
uh formula we first add the
probabilities of the leaves we can take
this directly from the input data and
then when we have an or node we can
compute easily the probability so the uh
probability that
this this Junction is true is one minus
that both uh variables are false and
this is the product of one minus the
probabilities of the variables we can do
the same computation at this Noe When we
arrive at a product note we can just
multiply the probabilities which we get
from the child trees we can do the same
computation on uh
uh the other side and then at the root
we get the probability that
the expression evaluates to True which
means that our initial query has at
least one output
tole
now I will uh show the last use case
which
is aggregate
computation let's again have a look at
our factorization with caching and
assume we want to compute the count so
we want to compute the number of output
topl in the query result we can do this
easily by one bottom up pass what we do
is we turn each note to one and we turn
each Union Noe to a plus and each
product Noe
to multiplication and then we go bottom
up at each note we do the corresponding
um
arithmetic operation on the
values we get from the uh child trees
and then at the top we get the overall
count in this case the count is
12 we can also do more complicated
Aggregates for instance let's say we
want to compute the sum over the prices
Group by pizza again we can do this in
one pass we turn each value to
one beside
the price because we don't want to
change the price we want to sum over the
prices and we also don't turn um pizza
into one because Pizza is a categorical
variable we rather map the pizzas to one
and then we do our bottom up computation
so for instance then when we arrive at
this note we know the sum of the prices
in this part was 36 so the overall sum
of the prices
for basilia is 36 and then we would add
this in uh to the root note and then we
do the same also for the branch
for haai
pizza we can now go a step further and
compute more complicated
um Aggregates and to do this we design
Rings
Rings not only help us to compute
complicated Aggregates but they also
help us to share computation between
the different Aggregates let me give you
an example let's say we want to compute
not only the sum one which is the count
but also we want to compute the sum of
all
the prices in the database and we want
to compute uh the sum over the prices
Group by Pizza
so we designed a ring whose elements are
now tuples of
three components one component for each
Aggregate and we redefine the meaning of
what means plus and time so um and here
is where we can share computation let me
give you uh what I mean by this so we
again go bottom up now at each note we
have three
components one for each aggregate let's
look at the root node so uh at root at
the root node we want first the overall
count to get the overall count we can
just multiply the count which we get
from the left tree with the count which
we get from the right
tree the sum of the to get the sum of
the prices we take the sum of the prices
from the right because yeah the price
appears here on the right tree but it
doesn't appear on the left tree from the
from uh the left we just take the count
because
for uh each price on the on the right
side will be repeated as many as the
count I get from here and then at the
end to uh know what is the sum of the
prices for let's say pilia we just map
pilia to the sum of the prices we
computed
before we can
also design an entire ring to compute
the co variance Matrix the co variance
Matrix is a matrix which for each pair
of variables in our data sets uh gives
the sum of the product of
their values and this Co variance Matrix
is very useful when we train for
instance machine learning models for
instance if we uh use
gradient descent this
Matrix represents the
data dependent
part and to compute this Matrix we
design a ring whose elements consist of
three components the first component is
is the count
this second component is a factor of um
sums over each single variable and the
third component is our Co variant Matrix
and now when we Define the plus and
times for this ring we see how we can
uh reuse computation let's look at
the definition of times and this part
shows how we compute the co variant
Matrix from the components we have
computed before so we here we use the
count uh and here we also use uh the
vector of the uh product over the single
variable
from the
um yeah uh from the first component and
this second component and then we also
um define the zero element and one
element which are trivial but the main
message is here that to uh compute this
Vector we we reuse the counts and to
compute the variance Matrix we
[Music]
reuse this vector and the
count and with this I am done with my
talk and thank you for
[Applause]
listening do we have
questions your last
example in your last
exampes you mention you Des this ring as
far as I can see for for these examples
you only need a semi ring right you're
only composing Su rings I guess the ring
only comes into play really if you want
to do updates exactly exactly yeah if
you are only in the static setting we
don't really need the ring we just need
this Sim ring but if you want to
maintain and
we did this in experiments so if you
want to maintain this ring then you need
this Co variance Matrix under updates
then you need
the the ring okay thank
you he thanks for the talk so how how do
you get the goods variable elimination
order to get a good
factorization yeah yeah this is an MP
heart problem so uh what what one can do
so there are
veristic we can follow we can for for
instance try to uh decompose the query
into hierarchical Parts this this would
be one way to do it but yeah overall the
problem is a is a hard problem we can
only use htics but there might be tics
available or you using your sticks in
practice to to get good compression yes
exactly okay in the the
DAT
exp yeah but but still I mean I mean if
you have have a
large query I mean in theory we consider
the query to be fixed so this can be
considered as as a constant Factor but
in practice you have to compute uh this
variable order and this can uh time can
with s soldiers because even a barrier
size 100
atoms asking because 100 atoms is an
unusual if you have 10 atoms is it a
problem that it's hard in the size of
asking do you really use ristics for
practical queries yes we use quistic
yeah yeah yeah but yeah I mean this
would be a good idea to use S S yeah I'm
May there by he's using sing to compute
hyper composition basically so I mean
from hyper composition you can extract
the elimination
order this could be and this pap says
it's
practically I don't remember what Ben
just they have an algorithm I don't
remember the r but yeah we can there is
a lot of work in the community um
similar in fact the end orer spaces that
I describe are quite similar to what
you and uh when the starting point is
the graphical model then there are
people are trying to find good
elimination order that will be the basis
also for the end of search this
structure that you describe is what I
call the sudo tree Tre so it appears in
various places maybe the starting point
is not the same and that in that
Community uh we use several tic that
known to be to work well such as mefi
and there are a variety of um algorithms
anytime algorithms that make compute
better better induced hold three and
they will
[Music]
impact composition in the same way so
these are very common everybody but he
looking exactly so it's not different
yeah but I would be surprised if there
is no relationship definitely so looking
at
this question okay thank you um yeah so
so you said that presing over fact datas
can be done in wor size up more time yes
so is it was over the size of the
factorized output or in the size of the
expanded output no no in the size of the
factorized output of course I oh so
actually otherwi it wouldn't be yeah
interesting because we know already that
we can do this in first case optimal
time right just using first case optimal
join algorithms yeah but here we are uh
so the computation time
is proportional to the size of the
factorization but the approach is
very similar to
known uh vers case optimal joint
algorithms in the sense that we go
variable by variable so we compute
joints uh over variables one by one
instead
of joining relations to I mean joining
one relation in once at a time I see but
the bound is much tighter as you show
yes thank
you clarification uh uh this reminds me
of work I did many years ago in
constraint community and there we
started by looking at database Community
because set of constraints is just a
database instance uh and uh we Bor I
mean so in database normally the input
is already factorized to two relations
so in this work you are exploiting
further DEC composition inside each of
the
relations so you are not assuming that
the and you are also doing it relative
to a query
yes okay yeah yeah yeah we are given a
query we look at the query and from the
query structure we uh see what kind of
conditional
Independence uh there must be in the
join result one can go even further so
this is some work done by Dani and I
forgot your name yeah where you start
with
the relation and look at the
distributions and try to extract from
the relation schema which exploits yeah
relation so I see so in constraints I
mean when you have a constraint
satisfaction problem it's all it's like
a query it's like a database query yeah
it's sort of a combination but it's a
can be perceived as a a database query
and there you are uh from the query you
have this constraint graph so you
extract a graph and from it you can
derive the conditional independencies
that you have so I don't know if this
can be immediately applied but that's uh
how it is done there although the the
queries are conjunctive just simply
conjunctive just a comment
okay are there any other
questions
yes
thanks uh so in knowledge compilation
when you want to solve a counting
problems or enumeration or if you just
want to factorize a buan function
usually you can look at circuit classes
that are not not structured but you
don't need the structuredness like
deterministic DEC composable and here
you seem to always want to have a
variable order so I was wondering if you
had looked at factorized databases
versions where you don't have a variable
order or if it doesn't make sense in
this context I mean we always considered
factorization related to variable orders
because
this guides us how to compute the
factorization and yeah this is an
important factor in our investigation
but no we yeah but so it could be the
case that you could compile further uh
like have a more compressor
representation if you don't impose a
variable order on the
question is whether we would still get
the nice properties we have like
con
enumeration aggregate computation in one
pass because we are mainly focused on uh
having efficient operations on top of
these Factor representation like in
machine learning aggregate computation
so not only in numeration yeah but it
would be uh we can talk about this more
uh maybe there are ways to yeah to get
rid of some uh structure in the variable
or then still uh achieve
good basically the main thing that you
will lose is the existential projection
all the siming projection when you want
to do group by because you need the
variable order sorry you need the
variable order here to protect it yes
but so if you lose the variable order
you can still aggregate efficiently on
the on the summering this is what
happens for ddn andf for example okay uh
but
one thing that is important in work is
to be able to project quantification and
to do gr by that you will lose but
otherwise you can do exactly I see the
same you need to adapt the compilation
algorithm that I will talk about this
this afternoon but so basically you can
do all this kind of thing too
okay okay so maybe we take questions
offline during lunch break and we think
the speaker again
right so